Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Welcome to The Rest Is History. As you know, we like to take suggestions from our listeners. And the other day, I had a text message from somebody I hadn't seen for many years who was at university with me, a man called John Tinker. Now, whereas I went into the world of history to serve the public, John Tinker went into the city and made an enormous
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。如你所知，我们喜欢采纳听众的建议。前几天，我收到了一条短信，发信人是我很多年没见的一位大学同学，一个叫约翰·丁克尔（John Tinker）的人。当年我投身历史界是为了服务公众，而约翰·丁克尔则闯荡伦敦金融城，赚取了海量的
amount of money. And from his baronial pile, he issued me with the following suggestion. He said it would be fascinating to do a podcast about a history of weather, or rather, the impact of the weather upon history. And for once, he was right. It is a good idea, and that's what Tom Holland and I are going to do. We're going to do the top 10 ways, or at least our top 10 ways, that the weather has changed the course of history. Tom, are you looking forward to this? Are you excited? I am.
财富。他从他的豪宅里向我提出了这样一个建议。他说，做一个关于天气历史的播客，或者更准确地说，关于天气对历史影响的播客，一定会非常吸引人。而这一次，他说对了。这是一个好主意，这也是汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland）和我接下来要做的事。我们将盘点天气改变历史进程的十大方式，或者至少是我们心目中的十大方式。汤姆，你对这个话题期待吗？你兴奋吗？我很期待。
And I've been very prepped by just being downstairs. And my younger daughter is in a furious debate with her friends about whether to go to a festival in Sussex. And the reason there's a debate is that it is pissing down as we sit here. And we've just finished recording an episode on the Western Front with Gary Sheffield. Lots of talk about the mud of Passchendaele. And I think that they could go
而且我刚从楼下来，受到的“教育”还挺深刻的。我的小女儿正和她的朋友们激烈争论，到底要不要去萨塞克斯郡（Sussex）的一个音乐节。争论的原因是，就在我们坐在这里录音的时候，外面正下着倾盆大雨。我们刚刚和加里·谢菲尔德（Gary Sheffield）录完一期关于西线战场的节目，里面聊了很多关于帕斯尚尔（Passchendaele）泥潭的事情。我想她们如果今晚去萨塞克斯郡的话，
and experience something akin to that if they go down to Sussex tonight. So I'm very excited. Yeah, it is character building. So I said, yeah, absolutely, you should go. But of course, it's not just weather, is it? We're also going to talk about climate. And there is a difference between the two.
可能会体验到类似的情景。所以我非常兴奋。是的，这能磨炼人的意志。所以我说，当然啦，你们绝对应该去。不过话说回来，这不仅仅关乎天气，对吧？我们还要聊到气候。这两者是有区别的。
What is it? I've actually never bothered to inform myself, to educate myself, as the young people say, about this. What is the difference between weather and climate? Weather happens day to day. Climate happens over the sweep of the centuries and the millennia. So that's why it's climate change rather than weather change. So we're actually doing both, aren't we, in this podcast?
区别在哪？说实话，我从来没有费心去了解过，用年轻人的话说，就是去“自我教育”一番。天气和气候到底有什么区别？天气是日复一日的。气候则是跨越数百年乃至数千年的宏大变迁。所以我们才叫气候变化，而不是天气变化。所以在这期播客里，我们其实要把这两者都讲了，对吧？
Yeah, we are. Because I know what we're going to be talking about. And there's weather here and climate. So on the topic of climate, can I kick off with mine? I think you should kick off, because I bet you're going to do something very old. Yes, incredibly old. Go on.
是的，没错。因为我知道我们要讨论的内容，这里既有天气，也有气候。那么关于气候这个话题，我能先抛砖引玉吗？我觉得你先说比较好，因为我敢打赌你要讲非常古老的东西。是的，极其古老。请讲吧。
So my nomination is the Ice Age. Okay, well, that's pretty obvious. You've gone for the big one basically i have well and you know that we're still living in the ice age is that that i did not know yeah we're living in the ice age because there is ice on the uh caps the polar caps right that's a very broad definition of the ice age though isn't because uh up until about two and a half million years ago there was no ice on the ice caps. That I did not know.
所以我的提名是冰河时代。好吧，那挺明显的。你基本上选了个最大的。我选了。而且你知道我们现在其实还生活在冰河时代吗？这件事我当时并不知道。对，我们还生活在冰河时代，因为南北两极的冰盖还在。不过，冰河时代这个定义非常宽泛，对吧？因为在大约两百五十万年以前，冰盖上是没有冰的。这件事我真不知道。
I've learned two things already. Do you know when the last ice age was before that? I bet you don't, but I do. That's why I've asked you. Yeah, of course. It was in the Permian period, which is the period just before the dinosaurs. As a friend of mine once said to me, you don't really know that. You just read that in a book.
我已经学到两件事了。你知道在此之前上一次冰河时代是什么时候吗？我敢打赌你不知道，但我知道。这就是我为什么问你。对，当然。那是在二叠纪（Permian），也就是恐龙出现之前的那个时期。正如我的一个朋友曾经对我说的那样：“你其实并不真的知道，你只是从书上读到的。”
I do know that because you know I love dinosaurs. You know I know me you don't really know that you just read that in a book i do know that you know i love dinosaurs you know i know that you know it was called it was called the karoo ice age but we so we are living in the in the um uh cortenery ice age okay um and um so it's basically it's been going on for two and a half million years and the ice caps, the glaciation comes and it goes. And I guess what we tend to think of as the ice age is known by geologists and climatologists as the last glacial maximum, by which they mean that the ice sheets have kind of descended to their lowest level and then they kind of slowly retreat. And so basically about 11 11 700 years ago that's when it ended and and that's when a period called the holocene which means the holy new period begins so the whole of history occupies the holocene the period after the ice age so what
我是真的知道，因为你知道我喜欢恐龙。你知道我……你其实并不真的知道，你只是从书上读到的。我是真的知道，你知道我喜欢恐龙，你知道我……你知道那被称为卡鲁冰河时代（Karoo Ice Age）。所以我们现在生活在第四纪（Quaternary）冰河时代。好吧，呃，基本上它已经持续了两百五十万年了，冰盖的冰川作用时而来临，时而消退。我想我们通常认为的冰河时代，在地质学家和气候学家看来被称为“末次冰盛期”（last glacial maximum），他们的意思是冰原已经下降到了最低点，然后又开始慢慢退缩。所以大约在11700年前，冰河时代结束了，一个叫做“全新世”（Holocene）的时期开始了，这个词的意思是“完全崭新的时期”。因此，整个人类历史都发生在全新世，也就是冰河时代之后的时期。所以我们现在
we're in now yeah exactly so so i think that that obviously that's absolutely huge and it's been focused for me by a trip that I've just done around Middle England. This very glamorous holiday of yours where you went to Leicester. Your stamping ground. But one of the places I went to, which is such a wonderful place, is literally on the Derbyshire-Nottinghamshire border. A place called Creswell Crags. Have you ever been? Never.
正身处其中，对吧？完全正确。所以我觉得这当然意义重大，而且我刚完成的一趟英格兰中部之旅让我对这一点有了更深刻的体会。你那次去了莱斯特（Leicester）的奢华度假之旅。那是你的老地盘。但我去的其中一个地方是个非常美妙的去处，它实际上位于德比郡（Derbyshire）和诺丁汉郡（Nottinghamshire）的边界上。一个叫做克雷斯韦尔峭壁（Creswell Crags）的地方。你去过吗？从来没有。
It's really wonderful. So it's kind of mining land. So kind of pot mark with mines and things. But this is a kind of series of – it's a ravine with caves on either side. And there's a lake there now, which got blocked off by the Duke of Portland because he was threatened with someone was going to build a railway through it. So he made a lake so that they couldn't build it, which I think HST protesters might want to – I mean, it's kind of a radical solution. And these caves, they contain the old Britain's only known cave art and a wonderful kind of fragment of bone on which someone carved a horse about kind of 13,000 years ago. So it's the oldest piece of British art. But it's incredibly atmospheric because this was about, I guess, about 10 miles from the Great Wall of Ice.
那里的景色真的很美。那片土地有点像是采矿区，到处都是矿坑之类的痕迹。但这里其实是一系列——这是一个峡谷，两旁都有洞穴。现在那里有一个湖，当年波特兰公爵（Duke of Portland）把湖水截断，因为有人威胁要在那儿修建一条铁路。于是他造了一个湖，这样他们就没法修铁路了，我想这可能会让英国高速铁路（HS2）的抗议者们想要……我的意思是，这算是一种激进的解决办法。这些洞穴里保留了英国仅知的唯一一处洞穴壁画，还有一块精美的骨头碎片，大约在13000年前，有人在上面雕刻了一匹马。所以这是英国最古老的艺术品。但那里极具氛围感，因为这里距离那堵巨大的冰墙大概只有，我猜，大约10英里远。
So it's like Game of Thrones. You know, that Wall of Ice was somewhere kind of north Nottinghamshire. And Creswell Crags was about as far as you could get back in those days and not kind of run into this wall of ice. So hold on, there were people and there was the wall of ice. Is that correct? So there's a wall of ice and then basically there's tundra just south of that. And every summer people would make the journey up north
所以这就像是《权力的游戏》里的场景。你知道，那堵冰墙大概就在诺丁汉郡北部某个地方。而克雷斯韦尔峭壁就是当年人们能够北上的极限了，再往前走就会撞上这堵冰墙。等等，那时既有人类，也有冰墙？是这样吗？所以那里有一堵冰墙，然后在它的正南方便是苔原。每年夏天，人们都会向北迁徙，
and Creswell Crags seems to have been about as far north as they would go and they would take shelter in the caves. And I guess they'd use it because this great kind of troops of deer and whatever would be funneled through this or they could trap them there or they could kind of drive them off the cliffs or whatever. So it was a way of finding food even in the kind of absolute teeth of this horrific Arctic weather. And then gradually it retreats and the glaciers retreat and slowly Yorkshire emerges and then Scotland and then Iceland and civilisation begins. A great chorus of complaint emerging out of that.
而克雷斯韦尔峭壁似乎就是他们能到达的最北端，他们会在山洞里避难。我想他们会利用这一点，因为成群结队的鹿之类的动物会被驱赶到这里，或者他们可以在这里设陷阱把它们困住，或者把它们赶下悬崖什么的。所以，即使在面对这种极其可怕的北极严寒天气时，这也是一种寻找食物的方式。然后冰川逐渐退缩，约克郡显露出来，接着是苏格兰，然后是冰岛，文明由此开始。听众中随之传出一阵巨大的抱怨声。
Yes, so wide and slowly. With huge apologies to everyone north of Nottinghamshire there that was dominic's joke not mine um so that basically makes british history possible because without the end of the ice age simply you know people wouldn't be able to live here permanently um but also it has a kind of measurable impact say further south where the ice hasn't reached so in the middle east the near east where civilization begins it's around the time that that the the last glacial period ends that you start to get the very very beginnings of urban civilization so within about uh 200 years of the the end of the ice age in jerichoicho, you've got about 1,000 people
是的，所以是“广泛而缓慢地”展现。向诺丁汉郡以北的所有人致以万分的歉意，那是多米尼克的玩笑，不是我的。嗯，所以这基本上为英国历史的诞生创造了可能，因为如果没有冰河时代的大结局，简单来说，人们就无法在这里永久居住。但它也对其他地方产生了可测量的影响，比如冰川未曾到达的更南方的地区。所以在中东，也就是近东——文明的起点，正是在末次冰川期结束的那个时期，你开始看到城市文明最初的萌芽。因此在大约——冰河时代在杰里科（Jericho）结束后的200年内，大约有1000人
living in a kind of proto-urban settlement. And that's the oldest city in the history of Jericho? Yeah, pretty much. It's continuously inhabited right the way through. So anyway, that's mine. That's my personal relation. So hold on. Just a quick question.
生活在一个原始的城市聚落里。杰里科是历史上最古老的城市吗？是的，差不多是这样。它一直有人连续居住到现在。不管怎样，这是我的提名。这是我个人的亲身关联。等等。我有个简单的问题。
Are people living in Jericho, in other words, within a few generations of the people doing the horse at the crags? Yeah, about 1,000 years. 1,000 years between the two things. Yeah. So that's quite close, isn't it? Yeah.
杰里科的人类，换句话说，是和在峭壁上雕刻马匹的那群人相距短短几代人吗？大约相差1000年。这两者之间相隔1000年。所以这其实挺近的，对吧？
That's an extraordinary thought when you think of the beginnings of civilization. Yeah, and in the Near East, there are these kind of settlements that keep kind of popping up. And then you have kind of cold periods intervene. So there's one called the Younger Dryas, which sounds like something out of Narnia or something. But it's a cold spell that lasts for about 1500 years. And so the incipient process of urbanization in the Near East retreats.
当我们想到文明的起源时，这是一个非凡的想法。是的，在近东，这类定居点不断涌现。然后你会经历寒冷时期的干预。其中有一个时期叫做“新仙女木期”（Younger Dryas），听起来像是纳尼亚传奇里的东西。但这是一个持续了大约1500年的寒冷期。因此，近东地区刚刚萌芽的城市化进程又退缩了。
And then the Younger Dryas ends, the Ice Age ends, and boom, we're off. Okay. On the long road to iPhonesiphones and podcasts yeah podcasts i'd never thought of this podcast as the summit of civilization and human achievement but now of course i do yeah um okay i buy that that i mean no one could possibly argue with that could they i actually feel slightly humiliated because you've chosen the Ice Age, and my first one is the Little Ice Age. That's not a metaphor. Bless. Adorable. Yeah.
接着新仙女木期结束，冰河时代结束，然后轰的一声，我们出发了。好的。踏上了通往iPhone和播客漫长道路。是的，播客。我以前从来没想过这个播客竟然是文明和人类成就的巅峰，但现在我当然这么认为了。好吧，我接受这个说法。我的意思是，没有人会反驳这一点吧？我其实感到有点羞愧，因为你选择了冰河时代，而我的第一个选择却是小冰期。这不是隐喻。天哪，太可爱了。
So, yes, have you read the book called Global Crisis by somebody called Geoffrey Parker? I have. Yeah, it's fantastic. Amazing book. It's about 7,000 pages long. Full of horrible stuff about China. Yeah, it's all about the 17th century.
所以，是的，你读过杰弗里·帕克（Geoffrey Parker）写的名叫《全球危机》（Global Crisis）那本书吗？我读过。太棒了。一本惊艳的书。大约有7000页厚。里面充满了关于中国的可怕内容。是的，书里讲的全是17世纪的事情。
So we've done a 17th century podcast. We've touched on the 17th century many times. And this book is about the 17th century as a global phenomenon. So the age of the 30 Years War and the British Civil Wars and so on, but all across the world. And basically, a lot of historians are now fascinated by the issue of climate and climate change. And Geoffrey Parker, who was always a historian, I think, of war, really, of sort of early modern warfare he's now looked at this and he says you know the data is absolutely clear in the course of the little ice age so in the course of roughly the 17th century temperatures dropped by about two
所以我们做过一期关于17世纪的播客。我们多次触及过17世纪。而这本书把17世纪作为一个全球现象来探讨。所以这是三十年战争和英国内战等事件的时代，但它是放眼全世界的。基本上，现在许多历史学家都对气候和气候变化的问题着迷。而杰弗里·帕克，我认为他一直是一位历史学家，主要是研究战争的，研究某种早期现代战争的，现在他审视了这一点，并且他说，你知道，数据非常清晰，在小冰期期间，也就是说在大约整个17世纪，气温下降了大约两
degrees and you know one of the reasons why some people think this is no you don't know any of the reasons no that's great well one of them is the spanish conquest of the reasons? No. That's great. Well, one of them is the Spanish conquest of the Americas. So because it sort of decimated agriculture in some way that I don't comprehend because I know nothing of science, that affected the climate. And there was generally a climate drop. Is there more smelting? There may well be. I mean, yeah, I suppose. Well, hold on.
度。而且你知道为什么有些人认为这不是——不，你不知道任何原因？不，这很好。其中一个原因是西班牙对美洲的征服。因为这以某种我无法理解的方式摧毁了农业，因为我对科学一无所知，这影响了气候。而且当时普遍出现了气温下降。是因为有更多的冶炼活动吗？很可能有。我是说，对，我猜。等等。
Smelting? Would smelting not be... Well, I know in the early Roman period, there's a lot of smelting. And this impacts on ice cores in Greenland. But wouldn't that heat things up? Don't know. Okay. Well, this is top quality podcasting.
冶炼？难道冶炼不会……嗯，我知道在古罗马时期，有很多冶炼活动。这会影响格陵兰岛的冰芯。但难道这不会让气候变暖吗？不知道。好吧。总之，这是一期高质量的播客。
Anyway, let's get back to what we do know about. So we know that there's a crisis that begins in the 1610s. So that's round about the outbreak of the Thirty Years' War in Germany. So you've got snow in Japan. You have a huge drought in sub-Saharan Africa. You have rivers drying up in the New World. And basically, harvests failing and all this sort of carry on. And there are some amazing stories.
无论如何，让我们回到我们真正了解的事情上来。所以我们知道，一场危机在1610年代开始了。这大约是在德国三十年战争爆发的时期。日本下起了雪；撒哈拉以南非洲发生了大旱；新世界的河流干涸；基本上农作物品收成失败，诸如此类的事情接踵而至。而且有一些惊人的故事。
So people, you can walk across the Bosphorus on the ice. It's so cold from um constantinople so you can walk from europe to asia which is a cool thing to do without using it and they have ice fairs don't they on the thames yeah and later on obviously the frost fairs on the thames so this continues and the frost fairs on the thames i think are sort of 1660s ish or so um people do bear baiting on the Thames and things, and, I don't know, play football and buy snacks and stuff and dance and all these kinds of things. But there's sort of horrific consequences. So thousands upon thousands of people, I mean, starve to death.
所以人们，你可以踩着冰走过博斯普鲁斯海峡（Bosphorus）。从君士坦丁堡出发，那里冷得你可以直接从欧洲走到亚洲，这是一件很酷的事情，不用……而且他们在泰晤士河上举办冰上集市，对吧？是的，毫无疑问，后来泰晤士河上有了冰霜集市（frost fairs），所以这种情况一直在持续，泰晤士河上的冰霜集市我想大概是在1660年代左右吧。人们在泰晤士河上进行残酷的斗熊游戏之类的活动，还有，我不知道，踢足球、买零食、跳舞以及所有这类活动。但其中也有可怕的后果。成千上万的人，我是说，活活饿死了。
And in Germany in particular, you see the impact of the weather because harvest failures, you've got the Thirty Years' War, massive hailstorms, and this is the year of the witch craze so people are looking for somebody to blame for these climactic events that they can't you know they don't have the scientific tools to understand and they they basically say well it must be caused by you know that old woman at number 33 she's obviously a witch and so on and so forth and the stats are actually i mean we're usually quite a stat-free podcast but so china poland russia and the ottoman empire the population falls by about a third during this period in the in germany it falls by half half and that's not all the 30 years war a lot of it is the is the climate stuff and you're right
尤其是在德国，你能看到天气带来的冲击，因为农作物歉收，加上三十年战争，还有大规模的冰雹，而这也是疯狂猎巫的年份——所以人们在为这些气候事件寻找替罪羊，他们无法——你知道，他们没有科学工具去理解这些，他们基本上会说：“这一定是因为33号的那个老太婆，她显然是个女巫，”诸如此类。而统计数据实际上——我是说，我们通常是一个几乎没有统计数据的播客，但中国、波罗的海、俄罗斯和奥斯曼帝国的总人口在这个时期下降了大约三分之一；而在德国，人口下降了一半，整整一半！这并不全是因为三十年战争，很大一部分原因是气候问题。你提到中国时说得对，
when you mention china so it's a huge thing in China. You get the collapse of the Ming Dynasty and you have all kinds of famine and floods and the Qing or the Manchu Dynasty, they come along. So this is a real pivot in world history. And it's not just because of technology and religion and stuff. It's also because of the weather.
所以这对中国来说是一件大事。明朝崩溃了，你看到了各种各样的饥荒和洪水，然后清朝或满清王朝登上了历史舞台。所以这是世界历史上一个真正的转折点。这不仅仅是因为技术、宗教之类的事情，也是因为天气。
I remember in that Geoffrey Parker book that he quotes a poll that was taken five years after the Second World War in which Germans are asked, what is the worst political disaster that's ever afflicted Germany? And rather than picking the Second World War or the Nazis, they go 30 years war because I guess more people die. More. Proportionately. Yeah. It's amazing, isn't it?
我记得在杰弗里·帕克的书里，他引用了一项在二战后五年进行的民意调查，调查中德国人被问到：“曾经降临德国的最糟糕的政治灾难是什么？”他们没有选择第二次世界大战或纳粹，而是选择了三十年战争，我猜是因为有更多的人死亡。更多。按比例来说。是的，这太惊人了，不是吗？
We should do something on the 30 years walk Because it's so little known In English speaking countries And just so bizarre Swedish armies But I'm slightly nervous about doing it because it's so complicated And I can never remember who's fighting who Yeah but I don't think anybody else can either I know but you're meant to be the expert
我们应该做一期关于三十年战争的节目。因为在英语国家里，它太鲜为人知了，而且又如此诡异，里面还有瑞典军队。但我又有点担心去做这个节目，因为它太复杂了，我永远记不清谁在和谁打仗。是的，但我觉得别人也记不清。我知道，但你应该是专家啊。
I mean if we do a podcast We've got no idea what's going on We've never adopted that principle in this podcast. So I don't think people are going to expect expertise now. Anyway, give us one of your next examples. Okay, so we've had the Ice Age. We've had the Little Ice Age. And now I think it's time for a cooling.
如果连我们做播客的都不知道发生了什么……我们在这档播客里可从来没遵循过这种原则。所以我认为大家现在也不会指望我们有什么专业性。不管怎样，给我们讲讲你的下一个例子吧。好的，所以我们聊了冰河时代，聊了小冰期。现在我觉得是时候来点降温了。
So I'm going for the Late Antique Cooling. Cooling. Yeah, which begins in the middle of the 6th century AD. Is this related to earthquakes and stuff? It's probably related to the explosion, three explosions of volcanoes in succession. So 536, 539,
所以我选择晚古岁差时期的降温（Late Antique Little Ice Age）。降温。是的，它始于公元6世纪中叶。这跟地震之类的事有关吗？它可能与火山爆发有关，三次火山接连爆发。所以是536年、539年、
540, and 547. I hope people are taking notes. And 536, Procopius, the great historian and prurient obsessive who writes absolute filth the secret history Justinian and Theodora and if you haven't read it it's fine you know I don't want to put it get an e on our podcast rating so I'm not going to describe what the geese do
540年和547年。希望大家都在做笔记。而在536年，普罗科匹厄斯（Procopius），这位伟大的历史学家和好窥探隐私的怪咖，写下了绝对下流的东西——《秘史》（The Secret History）关于查士丁尼和狄奥多拉。如果你没读过也没关系，你知道的，我可不想让我们的播客评级拿到个“E”（不宜儿童），所以我不会去描述那些鹅都做了些什么。
but but if you're interested do read it anyway so Procopius has he's writing about the the uh the gothic wars in Italy when the the Byzant, the Romans are trying to recapture Italy from the Goths. And he says that in this year, the sun, the light, it gave no heat. And there's another guy, Cassiodorus, who says that the light of the sun is a kind of bluish quality, that the seasons get blurred, that you get snow and ice in, in, in the summer. In Irish annals, you get accounts of famine in,
不过，如果你感兴趣的话，一定要去读读。总之，普罗科匹厄斯在写关于意大利哥特战争的事情，当时拜占庭人，也就是罗马人，正试图从哥特人手中重新夺回意大利。他写道，在那一年，太阳的光芒没有提供任何热量。还有另一个人叫卡西奥多罗斯（Cassiodorus），他说太阳的光线有一种泛蓝的质感，季节变得模糊不清，你在夏天竟然能看到冰雪。在爱尔兰的编年史中，你也能看到关于饥荒的记载，
again, in China, horrible kind of details about the suffering, the famine, the, the, the awful experience of the people there. And there's a sense in which there's this kind of
同样，在中国，也有关于苦难、饥荒以及当地人民可怕遭遇的骇人细节。人们有一种感觉，仿佛存在着这样一种
dust veil and it seems to have led to a kind of century almost or maybe two centuries of very cool temperatures maybe going down by two or three degrees and all of this is incredibly contested and and complex because it's the interface between history, climatology, all kinds of things. But if you assume a drop in two to three degrees, then that implies famine. And basically this is a period where everybody is just above the subsistence level. And if the harvests fail,
尘埃面纱，它似乎导致了近一个世纪甚至两个世纪的非常寒冷的温度，气温可能下降了两到三度。所有这一切都充满了争议且错综复杂，因为这是历史学、气候学以及各种学科的交汇点。但如果你假设气温下降了两到三度，那就意味着饥荒。基本上，这是一个每个人都勉强维持在温饱线上的时期。如果农作物歉收，
even minutely, then people start to starve and it's in that context that the the two centuries that follow say 550 are incredibly convulsive and in in the in the mediterranean world the near eastern world basically this is the marking point between the end of antiquity and what will become the medieval world these are like the byzantine so yeah so that so the roman empire the byzantine empire it it kind of implodes it it retrenches but it's it's an absolute kind of shrunken parody of itself it when it emerges from this period the sassanian empire the persian empire
哪怕只有微小的程度，人们也会开始挨饿。正是在这种背景下，随后的两个世纪——比如从550年开始——充满了剧烈的动荡。在环地中海世界和近东世界，这基本上是古代的终结与未来中世纪世界的起点之间的分水岭。这些就像是拜占庭——所以，是的，罗马帝国、拜占庭帝国开始内爆，它开始收缩，但当它从这段时期走出时，它变成了自身一个绝对缩水版的滑稽模仿；萨珊波斯帝国彻底崩溃；伊斯兰教、哈里发国崛起；
collapses completely you have the emergence of islam the caliphate um in uh in scandinavia the latest estimate is that 50% of the population starves to death. And you'll know all the stories of Ragnarok, the Wolf Age, the Ice Age. So Neil Price, brilliant historian of the Viking period,
在斯堪的纳维亚，根据最新的估计，50%的人口活活饿死。你们肯定都知道诸神黄昏（Ragnarok）、狼之时代（Wolf Age）、冰河时代的种种故事。所以尼尔·普赖斯（Neil Price），这位杰出的维京时期历史学家，
argues that what's called the Thimble Winter is a folk memory of this period and that the kind of the convulsion the the the devastation that it brings to scandinavia is essentially what sets in train what will become the viking age um and uh in distant um mexico teotihuacan which you remember in the aztec episode um the aztec yeah there's this great great abandoned abandoned city, the kind of the Rome of Central America that the Aztec kings are going to on pilgrimage. You know, this is a vast city, a vast city.
认为被称为“芬布尔之冬”（Thimble Winter）的传说，其实是这段时期的一种民间记忆，它给斯堪的纳维亚带来的动荡和毁灭，本质上正是开启维京时代的导火索。而在遥远的墨西哥，特奥蒂瓦坎（Teotihuacan）——你们在阿兹特克那一集里还记得它，阿兹特克人——那里有一座巨大的废弃城市，就像中美洲的罗马一样，阿兹特克国王们会去那里朝圣。你知道，这是一座巨大的城市，一座庞大的城市。
It's kind of, you know, on the scale of Constantinople. But it implodes completely from 550 through the decades that follow. And so, again, people think that perhaps this is due to this global cooling. So at the moment, obviously, the focus is on global warming. But the experience of late antiquity suggests that cooling as well can have this completely devastating impact. That's pretty good. That gave us the Vikings, Islam, the end of the Mexican Rome, the implosion of the real Roman Empire. Yes. And so there is a, you know, historians are understandably nervous about these kind of catch-all explanations. And so there's a kind of growing consensus that the
它的规模，你知道的，和君士坦丁堡不相上下。但从550年开始直到随后的几十年里，它彻底内爆了。所以，人们再次认为这可能归咎于全球变冷。因此目前，人们的焦点显然集中在全球变暖上。但晚古岁差时期的经历表明，变冷同样会带来这种彻底的毁灭性影响。这挺不错的。这给我们带来了维京人、伊斯兰教、墨西哥罗马的终结，以及真正罗马帝国的内爆。是的。因此，历史学家对这种一概而论的解释感到紧张是可以理解的。于是出现了一种日益形成的共识，即
the climatological evidence does suggest that there really was a kind of process of global cooling in this period and therefore uh that puts you know it kind of provides an interesting slant on records of of well famine but also of course intriguingly plague and that's again an open question whether there's a connection between this drop in temperatures and the emergence of plague in the 6th century. But what just occurs to me, Tom, given what you were saying, is that, of course, the weather matters more further back in history you go. I mean, I'm not saying it doesn't matter now, but obviously your point about living just above the subsistence level and reliance on the harvest means that the weather looms so large in late antique history or ancient history or medieval history, even early modern. Much more so than it does now, actually, that the weather matters less now, probably, ironically, given that we're in a period of global heating, that it has mattered in recent years less than probably ever before in human history yeah and the irony is is that the reason for that is industrialization that's
气候学证据确实表明，这一时期确实发生过某种全球变冷的过程，因此——这为我们审视饥荒记录提供了一个有趣的视角，当然，也耐人寻味地涉及瘟疫。气温下降与6世纪瘟疫爆发之间是否存在联系，这同样是一个开放性的问题。但汤姆，鉴你刚才所说的话，我脑海中突然浮现出一个想法，那就是，历史离现在越久远，天气自然就越重要。我的并不是说它现在不重要，但很显然，你刚才提到的那种生活在温饱线边缘、极度依赖收成的状态，意味着天气在晚古时期、古代历史、中世纪历史甚至近代早期都占据着极其重要的地位。实际上，比现在重要得多。现在天气的重要性可能有所下降，具有讽刺意味的是，尽管我们正处于全球变暖的时期，但与人类历史上几乎任何时候相比，天气在近年来的重要性可能都是最低的。
enabled us to escape well for only temporarily though yeah and so you know it's kind of a moebius strip of climatological paradox this is all very depressing um yeah so cheer us up uh well i'm going to do something really i can can't really compete with the origins of Islam and the Vikings. Something that explains both. So I'm going to go a bit obscure. Are you familiar with the Great Northern War, Tom? Remind me. So this is another war that nobody knows about
是的，而这里的讽刺之处在于，造成这一现象的原因恰恰是工业化，它让我们得以逃脱——不过也只是暂时的。是的，所以这有点像是一个气候学悖论的莫比乌斯带。这一切都非常令人沮丧。是的，那就让我们振作起来吧。好吧，我要讲一个真正厉害的——我实在没法和伊斯兰教与维京人的起源相比。一个能同时解释这两者的事情。所以我打算挑一个稍微冷门一点的。汤姆，你熟悉大北方战争（Great Northern War）吗？提醒我一下。所以这是又一场在英语世界里
in this sort of English-speaking world. But it's a great war. I, but it's a great war. I mean, it is a great war. It's a fascinating war. So it's the war for control of the kind of northern world and for the Baltic between two empires. Peter the Great? Peter the Great?
无人知晓的战争。但这是一场伟大的战争。我……但这是一场伟大的战争。我是说，这确实是一场伟大的战争。这是一场引人入胜的战争。这是两个帝国为了争夺北方世界以及波罗的海控制权而进行的战争。彼得大帝？彼得大帝。
Peter the Great, yeah. Peter the Great, Tsar of Russia, and Charles XII, who is a huge figure, head of the King of Sweden, head of the Swedish Empire. Byron wrote a poem about him. Did he? Yeah. That I did not know. Of course, he was a great Byron man.
彼得大帝，是的。俄罗斯沙皇彼得大帝，以及查理十二世（Charles XII），一个重量级人物，瑞典国王，瑞典帝国的统治者。拜伦曾为他写过一首诗。是吗？对。这件事我当时并不知道。当然，他可是拜伦的超级大粉丝。
So they're fighting this massive war, and it's kind of winner-takes-all who's going to be the big northern or northeastern power. And that starts in 1700. And at about that point, you get another of these periods of cooling and you have what's called the great frost of 1709 so they've been fighting for quite a while the great frost happens now this is for reasons that we don't really understand temperatures in western europe drop to about minus 15 degrees centigrade Celsius. So the soil freezes and trees explode because their sap has frozen and people on Royal Navy
所以他们正在进行这场规模宏大的战争，这是一场决定谁能成为北方或东北方超级大国的生死之战。战争始于1700年。大约在那个时候，你迎来了又一个降温期，并遭遇了所谓的“1709年大严寒”（Great Frost of 1709）。他们已经打了好一会儿仗了，大严寒就这样降临了。原因我们至今没有完全搞明白，西欧的气温骤降至零下15摄氏度左右。
ships die because they're cold and the fish freeze in the rivers and all these sort of details. Now, Charles XII has launched his great gamble to destroy Russian power and to cement Sweden as the sort of imperial power in the north. So he's been fighting against somebody called Augustus the Strong. Great name. Crazy name. Crazy guy. Well, strong name, strong guy, I think is more accurate.
因此土壤被冻结，树木因为树液冻结而炸裂，英国皇家海军军舰上的水兵们被活活冻死，河里的鱼也被冻僵了，诸如此类的细节数不胜数。此时，查理十二世发起了他的一场巨大豪赌，旨在摧毁俄罗斯的势力，并巩固瑞典作为北方帝国霸主的地位。所以他一直在和一个叫强者奥古斯都（Augustus the Strong）的人作战。好名字。疯狂的名字。疯狂的家伙。嗯，名字很强，人也很强，我觉得这样形容更准确。
So he's been fighting Augustus the Strong. Is he strong? I don't know. I just know it's – I don't really know. I'm not familiar with Augustus the Strong's work. Does he go around lifting up heavy clocks. I just know it's... I don't really know. I'm not familiar with Augustus the Strong's work. Does he go around lifting up heavy clocks?
所以他一直在和强者奥古斯都作战。他真的很强吗？我不知道。我只知道这——我其实并不太清楚。我对强者奥古斯都的“作品”并不熟悉。他是不是到处去举笨重的钟表？我只知道这——我其实并不太清楚。我对强者奥古斯都的“作品”并不熟悉。他是不是到处去举笨重的钟表？
I like to think he... Well, he's Polish, so I don't know what he would be lifting. What do the Polish Poles... Probably, I see them as a clock-making people. Early modern Poles?
我宁愿相信他……好吧，他是波兰人，所以我不知道他会去举什么。波兰人会举什么……可能吧，我觉得他们是一个制作钟表的民族。近代早期的波兰人？
I don't know. Anyway, we're just wittering. Charles decides he's going to invade Russia at the start of 1708, so very bad timing. And Peter the Great... It's the first great instance, really,
我不知道。总之，我们只是在闲聊。查理决定在1708年初入侵俄罗斯，这可真是个极差的时机。而彼得大帝——
in Russian history of that thing that becomes so familiar, the Russians withdrawing and doing their scorched-earth territory. So Peter the Great withdraws. Charles XII keeps going. And he goes on and on into Russia. And he decides he's going to winter in the Ukraine, which makes sense because Ukraine is the breadbasket of the kind of Russian empire.
这是俄罗斯历史上第一次出现那种后来变得家喻户晓的战术，即俄罗斯人选择撤退并实行焦土政策。所以彼得大帝撤退了。查理十二世继续前进。他一路深入俄罗斯腹地。他决定在乌克兰过冬，这倒也合乎情理，因为乌克兰堪称俄罗斯帝国的粮仓。
And he's got allies there who are Cossacks. And he thinks he can resume the campaign in the spring of 1799. But the Great Frost intervenes. So his army is massively reduced by hunger and by famine and so on, probably about half its size. The Cossacks don't turn up, or a lot of them don't turn up, because they themselves are debilitated by the frost and they've got no food and all these kinds of things so charles is um
而且他在那里有同盟，也就是哥萨克人。他认为自己可以在1709年春天重新发起战役。但大严寒插手了。因此他的军队因饥饿和饥荒等原因而严重减员，规模大概缩减了一半。哥萨克人也没有出现，或者说他们中的很多人没有出现，因为他们自己也被严寒折磨得精疲力竭，手里也没有食物，诸如此类。所以查理的
shorter supplies and he attacks a place called poltava very famous battle in russian and swedish history again basically unknown in anglophone countries and the russians win this crushing crushing victory. They basically break Sweden's power. So now we think of Sweden as this sort of country of very pious, wild-swimming, IKEA-mongering social democrats. But it absolutely wasn't like that in the early 18th century.
补给变得捉襟见肘，他进攻了一个叫做波尔塔瓦（Poltava）的地方。这是俄罗斯和瑞典历史上非常著名的一场战役，但在英语国家里基本上无人知晓，而俄罗斯人取得了这场粉碎性的巨大胜利。他们基本上彻底击碎了瑞典的势力。所以现在我们把瑞典视为一个充满虔诚、热爱野外游泳、出售宜巴（宜家）商品的社会民主主义国家。但在18世纪初，它绝对不是这个样子的。
And it's because of that, because of the Great Frost and the Battle of Poltava, because their power was completely and utterly broken. Charles does this incredible thing, which is very Game of Thrones-like behaviour. He doesn't go back to Sweden. He goes south and he spends five years in the Ottoman Empire. Unexpected? Yeah, it is unexpected.
这一切之所以发生，都是因为大严寒和波尔塔瓦战役，因为他们的国力被彻彻底底地摧毁了。查理做了一件不可思议的事，这非常具有《权力的游戏》式的风格。他没有回瑞典，而是向南走去，在奥斯曼帝国待了五年。出乎意料？是的，确实出乎意料。
Why does he do that? To be honest, I don't really know because it's the least it's the last thing peter the great would expect him to do and so therefore that's why i'll do it i'll take an extended city break for five years in constantinople um i mean who wouldn't want to yeah we'll say the byron the byron poem mazepa is set in the aftermath of the battle of pultoa all right and what happens in the poem mazepaa is, I think, a Cossack. He is a Cossack, yeah. He's a Cossack, and he describes how he,
他为什么要这么做？老实说，我真的不知道，因为这是彼得大帝最意想不到他会做的事，所以正因如此我才要这么做。我要去君士坦丁堡享受一次为期五年的超长城市度假。我是说，谁会不想呢？我们提到了拜伦，拜伦的长诗《马泽帕》（Mazeppa）就以波尔塔瓦战役之后为背景。没错，诗里发生的事是，马泽帕，一个哥萨克人。他是个哥萨克，是的。他是个哥萨克，诗中描述了他——
I think he had slept with somebody's wife, and the outraged husband strips him naked and ties him onto the back of a horse. And the horse gallops across the steps. Okay. Well, he lives to tell the tale, obviously. But I think that's basically it. And it's a metaphor for the romantic imagination.'s very good maybe we should do a podcast about
我记得他好像和某个人的妻子睡了，愤怒的丈夫将他剥光衣服，绑在了一匹马的背上。然后那匹马在草原上狂奔。好吧。当然，他活了下来并讲述了这个故事。但我想这基本上就是这样。这是浪漫主义想象的一个隐喻。这非常棒，也许我们应该做一期关于
byron tommy you'd love that maybe we should and maybe byron will turn up later in the podcast oh that's exciting who knows tantalizing us yeah well i have so we've done four i should i just quickly do mine i think you do have to do another one before the break. Yeah, okay. So I'll do it very quickly. So obviously a famous way in which the weather can affect the course of history is winds shattering fleets. Spanish Armada. So Spanish Armada is the famous one. The winds that blow and destroy much of Xerxes' fleet in 480 when he's invading Greece. But the one I've gone for is the two Mongol invasions of Japan launched by Kublai Khan, the great Mongol, you know, the Mongols have conquered much of China. While Kublai Khan is ruling Northern China, his armies are invading Song China in the South.
拜伦的播客，汤姆，你一定会喜欢那期节目的。也许我们应该做一期，说不定拜伦等会儿还会在这期播客里出场呢。哦，太令人兴奋了，谁知道呢，真让人心痒。好吧，我已经——我们已经讲了四个了。我应该快速讲完我的最后一个吗？我觉得你在中场休息前确实还得再讲一个。是的，好吧。那我就长话短说。所以，天气能够影响历史进程的一个著名方式就是狂风摧毁舰队。西班牙无敌舰队。西班牙无敌舰队就是著名的例子。公元前480年薛西斯入侵希腊时，狂风大作，摧毁了他的大部分舰队。但我选择的例子是忽必烈汗发起的两次蒙古侵略日本的战争。伟大的蒙古人，你知道的，蒙古人已经征服了中国的大部分地区。当忽必烈汗统治中国北方时，他的军队正在南下征服南宋。
And over the course of his reign, Song China will fall fall to him so he'll end up ruling the whole of China and he has his eyes set on further conquest so he looks across the sea to Japan and he he sends a kind of rather kind of you know it's it's it's it's kind of like on Twitter if you get someone say why can't we be kind to each other you know that the person who's sending it is about to shout at you for something yeah uh so somebody says that you know they're just about you know that try and cancel you for something exactly so kubo khan sends a message saying all countries we think belong to the one family and therefore you should join our family and if you don't you're a warmonger and the japanese basically say you know piss off so kubo khan said he sends a huge fleet from korea which he's conquered yeah the fleet crosses to japan they attack various places and they they're the japanese
在他的统治期间，南宋将会灭亡，最终他将统治全中国。而他的目光放到了更远处的征服上，所以他望向大海彼岸的日本。他派出了某种——这有点像——你知道的，如果在推特上看到有人说“我们为什么不能对彼此好一点呢”，你就会知道发这条消息的人下一秒就要因为什么事情对你大发雷霆了。是的，所以有人会说——你知道，他们正准备因为某件事取消你的关注呢。没错，所以忽必烈汗派出一封信，上面写着“所有国家在我们看来都属于同一个大家庭，因此你们应该加入我们的大家庭，如果不加入，你们就是好战分子”。而日本人基本上回答说：“滚一边去。”于是忽必烈汗派出一支庞大的舰队从高丽（他已经征服了高丽）出发，
are completely you know they can't really put up a fight against them because they're up it's it's actually it's kind of a teeny bit like the aztecs and the spanish that the japanese don't really know what they're facing so when they Mongols more technologically advanced? They are. The Mongols have explosives. They probably have cannon, and they seem to have hand grenades that they fire. I don't picture the Mongols with hand grenades.
舰队横渡大海来到日本，他们袭击了各个地方，而日本人完全——你知道的，他们根本无力抵抗，因为他们面对的——其实这有点像阿兹特克人和西班牙人的对决，日本人根本不知道他们面对的是什么。所以当他们看到蒙古人时，蒙古人技术更先进吗？是的。蒙古人拥有火药武器。他们可能拥有大炮，而且似乎还使用了他们投掷的手榴弹。我脑海中的蒙古人可没有手榴弹。
I think it's the first use of hand grenades outside China. Wow. Whereas the Japanese, I mean, it's all samurai, so they're all terrifying. They've got very fast swords. I mean, not the kind of people you want to take on, but they're kind of very much in the mode of you start a battle
我想这是手榴弹在中国以外的首次使用。哇。而日本人，我的意思是，全都是武士，所以他们都极其可怕。他们拥有非常快的刀剑。我是说，可不是你想招惹的那类人，但他们的作战方式非常古板——你在一场战斗开始时
by firing an arrow, which the Mongols find hilarious. So basically it's looking really bad for Japan. And then you get this great typhoon which sweeps down and destroys the fleet. And this typhoon is called Kamikaze. So the Kamikaze destroys the fleet and this typhoon is called kamikaze so the kamikaze destroys the mongol fleet kublai khan you know he's he's not going to be put off by this so he sends emissaries to to the japanese and the japanese chop off their heads so this doesn't go down well so kublai khan is determined he's going to have another crack and by this point
先射出一支箭，蒙古人对此觉得荒谬无比。所以基本上这对日本来说情况非常糟糕。然后你迎来了席卷而下并摧毁了这支舰队的伟大台风。而这个台风被称为“神风”（Kamikaze）。所以神风摧毁了这支舰队。而这个台风被称为神风，所以神风摧毁了蒙古舰队。忽必烈汗——你知道的，他可不会轻易被这个吓退，所以他派使者去见日本人，而日本人砍掉了他们的脑袋。这下事情不妙了。因此忽必烈汗下定决心要再来一次。此时
he's conquered the south of china. He's conquered Song China. So he can launch a pincer attack. He can launch a fleet from Korea and from southern China. So that's what he does. The fleet's rendezvous. They're about to attack China, Japan, when again, whoosh, the kamikaze hits. Is that the noise of a kamikaze wind? Ooh.
他已经征服了中国南方。他已经征服了南宋。所以他可以发起钳形攻势。他可以同时从朝鲜和中国南方派出舰队。这就是他所做的。两支舰队会合了。他们正准备进攻中国——哦不，是日本，就在这时，又是一声呼啸，神风袭来。那是神风怒号的声音吗？哦。
Something like that. I think that's my impression of a kamikaze. is that is that the noise of a kamikaze wind something like that i think that's that's all right it's top quality uh top quality sound effects here um so so japan is saved um you know china never never conquers japan and obviously that so there's been debate about whether this is true or whether the japanese kind of invented it to show five minutes after five minutes going through it only now you tell me it may not be true but don't you know everything in ancient or medieval history people is it all made up or is it yeah but but and the reason why people have thought it may not be true is the uses the propagandistic uses to which it's put in the second world war because famously um the pilots who yes of course suicide pilots call themselves kamikazes and the hirohito the emperor kind of invokes this idea of the the typhoons
差不多是这样。我想这是我对神风的模仿。那是神风怒号的声音吗？差不多是这样。我觉得这还行。这是高品质的——高品质的音效。所以日本得救了。中国从未能征服日本。显然，关于这究竟是确有其事，还是日本人为了自我吹嘘而发明出来的，一直存在着争论。讲了五分钟之后，你现在才告诉我这可能不是真的？难道你不懂吗？在古代或中世纪历史上，人们说的话到底是全都是编造出来的还是——是的，但人们之所以认为它可能不是真的，是因为它在第二次世界大战中被用作政治宣传。因为众所周知，
coming to the rescue and the reason why people have thought that it may not be true is that typhoons on this scale are not a feature of the waters of Japan. But I'm relieved to say that geologists have recently done a study and doing something geological, which I don't understand, they have proved that actually back in the 13th century, Japan was much more prone to typhoons than now. And so therefore, it probably did happen. Could of course have been um that's that's yes i mean that's alternative theory so so i think that's good so that is good that's five isn't it so we've done five we're halfway through um so uh don't go away because
那些自杀式飞行员将自己称为“神风敢死队”，而裕仁天皇也借用了台风前来救援的这种观念。人们之所以认为这可能不是真的，是因为这种规模的台风并不是日本海域的常见特征。但令我感到宽慰的是，地质学家最近进行了一项研究，通过某种我无法理解的地质学方法，他们证明了在13世纪时，日本确实比现在更容易遭受台风袭击。所以，这件事大概率是真的。当然也可能是——那是另一种理论。所以我觉得这很棒。所以这是第五个，对吧？我们已经讲了五个，我们已经进行到一半了。所以大家不要走开，因为
we've got lots more yeah with a theme historical more of this scientific expertise that we're bringing to this topic possibly Possibly sound effects. Yeah. So, don't go. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip.
我们还有很多精彩内容。是的，我们将继续围绕历史主题带来更多科学专业知识。可能还有音效。所以，请不要离开。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《历史的娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝八卦的好去处。
And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History, to our weather-themed episode. We're looking at the top 10 times that the weather or indeed the climate influenced the course of history um i've just done my third so dominic it's your turn it is my turn what are you uh what's what's your um your nomination before i tell you i'll just say i'm
在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、独家番外并优先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史其余部分》，来到我们的天气主题节目。我们将盘点天气或气候影响历史进程的十大时刻，呃，我刚刚完成了我的第三个，多米尼克，轮到你了，轮到我了，你有什么，你的提名是什么，在我告诉你之前，我只想说我
still reading from the fact that you ended the the last the first half of the episode by saying to the audience don't go i don't think we should conduct our podcast with that level of desperation. Please don't go. Anyway, I don't think anyone will go when they listen to this because this is such good stuff. It's so gripping. So we did an episode about the French Revolution. And we talked briefly about the causes of the French Revolution.
依然对一件事耿耿于怀，那就是你在上一集前半部分结束时对听众说：“别走，我觉得我们不应该以那种绝望的程度来主持播客。”请别走。无论如何，我觉得当人们听到这个时，谁也不会走，因为这些内容太棒了。太引人入胜了。所以我们做了一集关于法国大革命的节目。我们简短地谈到了法国大革命的原因。
And one thing that we probably didn't spend enough time on was the impact of the weather. So certainly when I was studying the French Revolution for A-level many years ago the weather was barely mentioned at all I mean people sort of said offhand or you know bad harvests rain and stuff like that but but actually this is a genuinely fascinating story because we were saying earlier that the the weather seems to matter less as you come forward in history because people aren't living at a subsistence level. But this is an instance where the weather really does matter and has massive political consequences. So there'd been a volcanic eruption in Iceland in 1785, I think. What is it with these Icelandic volcanoes?
而有一件事我们可能没有花足够的时间去探讨，那就是天气的影响。当然，多年前我学A-level法国大革命时，几乎完全没有提到天气。我的意思是，人们只是顺口说一下，或者你知道的，糟糕的收成、下雨之类的话。但实际上，这是一个真正引人入胜的故事，因为我们之前说过，随着历史的推进，天气似乎变得不那么重要了，因为人们不再处于勉强糊口的生存水平。但这是一个天气确实重要并产生巨大政治后果的例子。因此，1785年左右，冰岛发生了一次火山爆发，我想是这样的。这些冰岛火山到底是是怎么回事？
Anyway, there's an explosion, and then you have cooling in the second half of the 1780s, so an issue that we've talked about before, cooling. And in the spring and summer of 1788, you get a massive drought across France. You get a huge crop failure. So the harvest is about half its usual level. And then you get this colossal hailstorm and i mean a massive massive hailstorm that kind of a massive one is that what you mean a massive i think that's a technical term used by hailstorm hailstormologists
无论如何，发生了一次爆炸，然后在18世纪80年代后半期，你经历了降温，所以这是我们之前讨论过的一个问题，降温。在1788年的春天和夏天，法国各地发生了大旱。农作物严重绝收。所以收成大约只有平常水平的一半。接着是一场巨大的冰雹，我是说一场非常巨大的冰雹，那种巨大的，你是这个意思吗，巨大的，我认为这是冰雹气象学家使用的一个专业术语
a monster hailstorm you get shed loads of snow. That's also a technical term. And then, of course, the one thing you always get with snow, this is also great scientific knowledge, you get floods because it melts. So all these French farmlands are flooded. So they had this sort of... A Thomas Schaffernacker of late 18th century history. Yeah. I was about to say it's a perfect storm.
一场怪物般的冰雹，你会得到大量的雪。这也是一个专业术语。然后，当然，你总会从雪中得到的一点，这也是极好的科学知识，因为雪会融化，所以你会遭遇洪水。因此，所有这些法国农田都被淹了。所以他们有了这种……18世纪末历史上的托马斯·沙费纳克（Thomas Schaffernacker）。对。我正要说这是一场完美的风暴。
Brilliant. Maybe that would be one weather metaphor too many. So, yeah, this is all awful and just this sort of combination of things. And so by 1789, bread prices have gone through the roof because there's so many shortages. So if you're a French peasant or, indeed, rather, if you're a French sort of worker, you are spending about half of your
太棒了。也许天气隐喻会用得太多了。所以，是的，这一切都很糟糕，正是这种种种因素的结合。因此，到了1789年，由于短缺严重，面包价格飞涨。所以如果你是一个法国农民，或者更确切地说，如果你是一个法国工薪阶层，你在1789年之前，大约要把一半的
income on bread before 1789. And then when you get to the summer of 1789, you're spending about 90% of your income on bread. And do you know when prices reach their highest level, Tom? A year and a day after the massive, massive hailstorm. Do you know when that would be? The 14th of July, 1789, the day of the storm in the Bastille. Now, I've read that fact, and it almost seems too good.
收入花在面包上。然后到了1789年夏天，你大约90%的收入都要用来买面包。你知道价格什么时候达到最高水平吗，汤姆？就在那场巨大无比的冰雹过后的一年零一天。你知道那会是什么时候吗？1789年7月14日，攻占巴士底狱的日子。现在，我读过这个事实，它几乎好得
You know, it seems like one of those facts that's just too perfect. It's a great fact, though. And I wonder whether it can really be true. But for the purposes of this podcast, let's pretend it's definitely true. And that's the hail. So this massive, massive hailstorm gave you the Reign of Terror, the guillotine, Nelson on the Bridge of Trafalgar, Napoleon, the Wellington Boot, and so much more.
让人难以置信。你知道，这看起来像是一个过于完美的历史事实。不过这是一个很棒的事实。我想知道它是否真的能成真。但为了这个播客的目的，让我们假装它是千真万确的。这就是冰雹。所以这场巨大无比的冰雹带来了恐怖统治、断头台、特拉法加海峡桥上的纳尔逊、拿破仑、威灵顿长靴，以及更多。
International human rights. Yeah. So much else. The tricolour flag, the Marseillaise. Yes. Yeah. Okay, well, continuing the French history theme. Yeah.
国际人权。是的。还有很多很多。三色旗，马赛曲。是的。好吧，延续法国历史的主题。是的。
I think we need a tub-thumping English victory over France. We always do. There's no podcast in which that's not true. So, I'm going to... 1415, Battle of Agincourt.
我觉得我们需要一场英格兰对法国大胜的震撼人心的场景。我们总是这样。没有哪个播客不是这样的。所以，我要讲……1415年，阿金库尔战役。
Very popular subjects in French schools. So, this is the second... This is Hundred Years' War, part two. Henry V, busy and giddy minds with foreign troubles.
在法国学校里非常受欢迎的科目。所以，这是第二场……这是百年战争，第二部分。亨利五世，让那些充满异国战乱而烦躁不安的头脑……
August of 1415, he lands in France to claim the French throne. Doesn't go brilliantly well. He kind of wastes time besieging Harfleur Harbour in Normandy. Once more into the breach. Once more into the breach. 22nd December, September it falls. It's not much to show for the enormous amount of money and investment that Henry's put in. So he decides that he's going to kind of try and fly the flag by marching from Hafla to Calais,
1415年8月，他在法国登陆以夺取法国王位。进展并不是非常顺利。他有点在浪费时间围攻诺曼底的哈弗勒尔港。再战一次，冲入防线。再战一次，冲入防线。12月22日，9月它陷落了。对于亨利投入的大量资金和投资来说，这并没有太多成果。所以他决定尝试通过从哈弗勒尔行军到加来来扬起国旗，
which England holds and has captured in 100 years or round one. So 8th of October, he leaves for Calais and he marches through Normandy up towards Calais and it's very wet and miserable and he starts to get shadowed by the French he reaches the Seine all the bridges have gone he has to kind of march down the Seine to to find a crossing point does so gets on the other side and the French are drawing in and 25th of october he based 24th of october he basically gets cornered by a village called agincourt and french vastly outnumbered the english and by quite how much is very very contested but um let's say by lots but that's the level of precision that we've had so far in this well we can't you'll know that this i mean this is hugely debated no nobody ever knows these stats today they're all made up aren't they when the sources
英格兰在100年前的第一轮中就占据并夺取了加来。所以10月8日，他动身前往加来，穿过诺曼底向加来行军，天气又湿又惨，他开始遭到法国人的尾随，他到达塞纳河时，所有的桥梁都断了，他不得不顺着塞纳河行军去寻找过河点，找到了，并到达了对岸，法国人正在逼近，10月25日，他——10月24日，他基本上被一个叫阿金库尔的村庄逼入绝境，法军人数远超英格兰军队，具体多多少非常有争议，但……可以说多得多，不过这就是我们目前对这场战役的精确程度了。好吧，你会知道这——我的意思是这争论得非常厉害，今天没有人真正知道这些统计数据，当历史资料出现时，它们都是杜撰的，不是吗？
and wildly exaggerated but i think i think we can safely say the english are outnumbered um they're demoralized they're wet they're miserable they don't really have many supplies um the french are much better equipped and so there is a kind of universal assumption that they're going to win the battle and as in the shakespeare play the French spend the night kind of gambling and deciding who's going to lay claim to the ransom of Henry. And it rains. So it's a miserable night. And the terrain that lies between the English and the French lines has recently been ploughed. And so the rain falls on this um this plowed soil and in the morning the um the knights on horseback charge across this and it's a disaster because uh they all just sink into the mud and the horses hooves churn it up even worse than it had been before so that by
而且被极大地夸大了，但我想——我想我们可以安全地说，英格兰人的数量处于劣势，呃，他们士气低落，浑身湿透，痛苦不堪，他们真的没有多少补给，呃，法国人的装备要好得多，因此有一种普遍的假设，即他们将赢得这场战役，就像莎士比亚戏剧中一样，法国人在赌博中度过了一夜，并决定由谁来索取亨利的赎金。而且下雨了。所以这是一个悲惨的夜晚。而位于英格兰和法国阵线之间的地形最近刚被犁过。因此雨水落在了这片被翻耕的土壤上，早晨，呃，骑马的骑士们冲过这里，这是一场灾难，因为，呃，他们全都陷入了泥潭中，马蹄把泥地搅得比以前更糟，以至于当
the time the the men french men at arms come to attack the English line, basically, you know, they're sinking up to their knees, perhaps up to their waist. If you get hit by an arrow and the English archers are kind of raining, you know, rain of death down on them, you'll drown because you'll just slump into the mud. You know, it's like the Battle of Passchendaele. Well, you're so heavy, aren't you?
法国重装骑兵前来攻击英格兰阵线时，基本上，你知道，他们陷入泥中深及膝盖，甚至可能到腰部。如果你被箭射中，而英格兰弓箭手正向他们倾泻，你知道，死亡之雨，你就会溺水，因为你会直接瘫倒在泥潭里。你知道，这就像帕斯尚尔战役。嗯，你太重了，不是吗？
You're so heavy. You're so heavy. And so basically it's just kind of massive pile up and you will, you know, you's like the Battle of Passchendaele. Well, you're so heavy, aren't you? You're so heavy. You're so heavy. And so basically it's just kind of massive pile up. And you drown in the mud or you suffocate and you've got the English arrows raining down on you. And it's all an absolute disaster. And the English win. Don't the English pile in?
你太重了。你太重了。所以基本上这只是一场大规模的踩踏，你会，你知道，这就像帕斯尚尔战役。嗯，你太重了，不是吗？你太重了。你太重了。所以基本上这只是一场大规模的踩踏。你在泥潭里溺水或窒息，而英格兰的箭雨倾泻在你身上。这一切都是一场绝对的灾难。英格兰人赢了。英格兰人不是蜂拥而上了吗？
Well, I say the English, but aren't there a lot of Welsh? A lot of Welsh, yeah. Flewellyn. Flewellyn in Henry V. All banter about a leek yes exciting and exciting to learn from from a Welsh fan of the podcast that the the Welsh for banter is banter yeah a word you can you can see why he's deploying that word to this podcast can't you absolutely um anyway so so so basically English win uh but they pay badly though don't they then don't they go around sort of stabbing daggers through there? Well, the French try and attack the baggage train.
嗯，我说的是英格兰人，但难道没有很多威尔士人吗？有很多威尔士人，是的。《亨利五世》中的弗鲁埃林。所有关于韭葱的玩笑，是的，从播客的一位威尔士粉丝那里听到并感到兴奋，威尔士语中的玩笑就是“banter”，是的，一个你可以看出他为什么要把这个词用在这个播客中的词，不是吗？当然，呃，无论如何，所以，所以，所以基本上英格兰人赢了，但他们付出了惨重的代价，不是吗？他们难道没有到处用短剑刺——？好吧，法国人试图攻击辎重部队。
Right. That's poor form. Very poor form. So the Battle of Agincourt, I mean, in the long run, obviously the English lose the Hundred Years' War because of Joan of Arc and the fact that France is just much bigger. But Agincourt is what enables Henry to come back in overwhelming force and conquer basically half of France, have himself crowned as king of,
对。那是很不地道的做法。非常不地道的做法。所以阿金库尔战役，我的意思是，从长远来看，由于圣女贞德以及法国体量大得多的事实，英格兰人显然输掉了百年战争。但阿金库尔战役让亨利得以卷土重来，以压倒性的兵力征服了基本上半个法国，让自己加冕为，
you know, his son will be king of both France and England. All goes wrong. But it is the cause of Shakespeare's play. I mean, I actually think Henry V is a terrible king. Whilst overrated, terrible. He's very Christian, Tom. You should love him. It's a bloody murderous, squalid business.
你知道，他的儿子将同时成为法国和英格兰的国王。一切都出了错。但这就是莎士比亚戏剧的起因。我的意思是，我实际上认为亨利五世是一个糟糕的国王。虽然被高估了，但确实糟糕。他非常虔诚，汤姆。你应该喜欢他。这是一场血腥、肮脏的杀戮买卖。
You could say that about so many things, wouldn't you? You could say that about Alexander the Great or Julius Caesar. You could, yes. You probably would. I probably would. But I think Agincourt is a kind of squalid business. But, you know, it gives us Shakespeare's play with the soaring poetry,
你可以对很多事情这么说，不是吗？你可以对亚历山大大帝或尤利乌斯·凯撒这么说。是的，你可以。你可能会这么说。我可能会。但我认为阿金库尔是一场肮脏的买卖。不过，你知道，它给我们带来了带有高亢诗意的莎士比亚戏剧，
and it wouldn't have happened without the weather. Okay. Yeah, you don't need to persuade me. I'll give you that. That's a good one. So my next one is another French-based, war-based one. It's kind of a some uh listeners may sort of have seen this coming but i don't think we should ever be afraid of the obvious we never have been
如果没有天气，这一切都不会发生。好吧。是的，你不需要说服我。我承认这一点。这是一个很好的例子。所以我的下一个例子是另一个基于法国、基于战争的例子。这有点像一些呃听众可能已经预料到了这一点，但我觉得我们永远不应该害怕显而易见的事物，我们从来没有
so far um so it's d-day and it's a weather forecast actually rather than the weather itself so um it's a some people will know this story because um a very great actor and writer david haig did a play about it i think called pressure and it's the story because a very great actor and writer, David Hague, did a play about it, I think, called Pressure. And it's the story of a man called Brute Captain James Stagg. So he's basically an army or military meteorologist. And basically, they know they want to attack France in 1944. They're going to do these landings. And they have to pick the right date to do it.
到目前为止，呃，所以这就是诺曼底登陆，实际上是天气预报，而不是天气本身，所以，呃，有些人会知道这个故事，因为，呃，一位非常伟大的演员和作家大卫·黑格（David Haig）就此排过一出戏，我想叫《压力》。故事的主角是一个叫残酷的詹姆斯·斯塔格（James Stagg）上校的人。所以他基本上是一位陆军或军事气象学家。基本上，他们知道他们想在1944年进攻法国。他们要进行这些登陆。他们必须选择正确的日期来做这件事。
And they basically need a whole combination of very complicated things so for the air operations they need clear skies and they need a full moon for the sea operations they need the not can't be windy and the seas have obviously have to be reasonably calm and for the ground troops ideally they'll land at low tide because then all the german obstacles that are on the beach that you'll have seen in photos the sort of strange devices that the germans have um they will be exposed you know they won't be covered by water and so they'll be easier to to deal with and so you need a combination of these things and they have these weather forecasters who say basically the ideal window is between the 5th and the 7th of june um But when, you know, they have to pick a day and Group Captain Stagg and his team
他们基本上需要各种非常复杂因素的结合，对于空中行动，他们需要晴朗的天空，他们需要满月；对于海上行动，他们需要不能有风，海面显然必须相当平静；对于地面部队，理想情况下他们应该在退潮时登陆，因为那样所有在海滩上的德国障碍物——你会在照片中看到的那种德国人拥有的奇怪装置——将会暴露出来，你知道它们不会被水覆盖，因此会更容易处理，所以你需要这些因素的组合，他们有这些气象预报员，基本上说理想的窗口期是在6月5日到7日之间，
are sort of looking at the weather and famously the weather in the Channel is incredibly hard to predict and incredibly kind of variable and can turn on a sixpence from blue sunny skies to kind of storms and stuff. So they persuade Eisenhower to postpone the operation on the 4th of June, to postpone it by 24 hours.
但是当，你知道，他们必须选择一天，斯塔格上校和他的团队
But he can't keep putting it off because if you don't do it now, you'll have to wait for another two weeks. And the Germans will probably find out. You can only delude the Germans for so long. So there's this amazing moment late on the evening of the 4th of June. Eisenhower's in this house outside Portsmouth. And there's kind of wind howling outside. It's very kind of Byronic weather. The rain lashing at the windows.
正在观察天气，众所周知，英吉利海峡的天气极其难以预测，极其多变，可能会在六便士之间从湛蓝的晴空变成风暴之类的。所以在6月4日，他们说服艾森豪威尔推迟行动，推迟24小时。
And basically, Stag goes in and he says, it's not going to be ideal weather on Tuesday the 6th of June, but it's probably the best chance we'll have and I reckon you should go for it. And there's this wonderful moment where Eisenhower kind of looks over at this little figure hunched in an armchair
但他不能一直推迟，如果你现在不做，你就得等两周。而且德国人可能会发现。你只能愚弄德国人一段时间。所以在6月4日深夜，发生了这样一个神奇的时刻。艾森豪威尔在朴茨茅斯郊外的这座房子里。外面风呼呼地刮着。这是一种非常拜伦式的天气。雨水猛烈地打在窗户上。
and says, you know, what do you think? And the figure says, I think we should go for it. And that figure is, do you know who that figure is, Tom? Albert Einstein. It's Monty. It's Monty. Oh, Monty, yes. It's Monty.
基本上，斯塔格走了进去，他说，6月6日星期二的天气不会是理想的，但它可能是我们拥有的最好机会，我认为你应该放手一搏。有一个美妙的时刻，艾森豪威尔抬头看着这个蜷缩在单人沙发里的小身影，
So Montgomery says, I think we should go for it. And they do go for it. Now, they could easily not have gone for it. They could have been conservative and said, let's delay it by two weeks. And if they had done, you know what would have happened? They'd have been in the middle of a massive storm because on the 19th of june there was a colossal storm hit the channel so who knows what would have happened probably thousands of people would have died probably they'd have gone for it and rather than put it off again and thousands of people would have died who otherwise lived so um stags weather forecast
说，你知道，你觉得怎么样？那个人说，我认为我们应该放手一搏。那个身影是，你知道那个身影是谁吗，汤姆？阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦。是蒙蒂。是蒙蒂。哦，蒙蒂，是的。是蒙蒂。
save the day and you know we should have a statue in Whitehall to the weather forecasters of Britain. Also, most of, I mean, all the other ones have been about terrible things that happen and people dying in multitudes. And that's one that saved lives. So, yeah, you know, it's kind of, it's an interesting, of the maxim that awful things tend to make history. Yes, that's true true so bad weather makes
所以蒙哥马利说，我认为我们应该放手一搏。他们就真的放手一搏了。现在，他们完全可以不放手一搏。他们可以采取保守态度，说，让我们推迟两周吧。如果他们那样做了，你知道会发生什么吗？他们会置身于一场巨大的风暴之中，因为在6月19日，一场巨大的风暴袭击了海峡，谁知道会发生什么，可能数千人会死，可能他们会硬着头皮去干，而不是再次推迟，结果数千本可以活下来的人会死去，所以，呃，斯塔格的天气预报
history good weather tends not to i don't think we've got yeah we don't really have examples of i've my my last example is not a good weather example at all is yours uh well well good things come from it okay so i said i said so i said that um uh we'd have some more Byron. Yeah. I'm excited about it. So this is the famous year without a summer, which was 1816. And again, it's a kind of cooling. It's caused by volcano, in this case, a massive explosion in Indonesia,
拯救了一天，你知道，我们在白厅应该为英国的气象预报员树立一座雕像。另外，大多数，我的意思是，所有其他例子都是关于可怕的事情发生以及成千上万的人死亡。而这是一个拯救了生命的例子。所以，是的，你知道，这有点，这是一个有趣的例子，印证了“可怕的事情往往会创造历史”这句格言。是的，这千真万确，所以糟糕的天气创造了
Dutch East Indies as was, which happens in the spring of 1815. It erupts for a week and it's... Another great sound effect. Yeah, so I've done the typhoon. That's my impression of Mount Tambora exploding. And it's, you know, the impact of the kind of ash layer, it's like a kind of a brief winter, a global winter. And the ash dims the sun. And the effects endure into 1816.
历史，好的天气往往不会。我不认为我们有，是的，我们真的没有例子……我的最后一个例子根本不是一个好天气的例子，你的呢？嗯，嗯，会有好事从中产生的。好吧，我刚才说，我刚才说，呃，呃，我们会讲更多关于拜伦的内容。是的。我对此很兴奋。所以这就是著名的无夏之年，即1816年。同样，这也是一种降温。它是由火山引起的，在这种情况下，是印度尼西亚的一次大爆发，
And we've talked about subsistence. 1816 is the last year that people in Paris starve because the harvest has failed. And you get terrible conditions as well say in germany um the rhine it's it said is um is rotten with corpses people are dying but also uh it's not just um humans who are dying of starvation so also are horses and in germany nobody think of the horses well no one think of the horses. Well, no one think of the horses. And that means that basically transport's wiped out. Okay. You can't ride.
当时的荷属东印度群岛，发生在1815年春天。它喷发了一个星期，而且……另一个棒极了的声音效果。是的，所以我模仿了台风。这是我对坦博拉火山爆发的印象。而且，你知道，火山灰层的影响，就像一个短暂的冬天，一个全球性的冬天。火山灰使太阳变暗。这种影响一直持续到1816年。
You can't hitch them to wagons or to carriages or whatever. So there is a baron, Karl Drees, who thinks... He's an inventor. And so he invented... To get around this problem, he invents a laufmaschine, a running machine, which is the prototype of the bicycle. Oh, that's a good fact. So that's one positive that comes out of this, out of the year without a great section of English literature because that summer Lord Byron has left England under very dark circumstances. He's basically been canceled by a censorious English press and public,
我们讨论过勉强糊口。1816年是巴黎人因收成失败而挨饿的最后一年。你会遇到可怕的情况，比如在德国，莱茵河，据说，充满了尸体，人们在死去，而且，呃，不仅是人类在挨饿致死，马匹也是如此，而在德国，没有人关心马匹。好吧，没有人关心马匹。好吧，没有人关心马匹。这意味着基本上交通瘫痪了。好吧。你不能骑马。
um, because of a marital scandal involving incest and, uh, rumors of sodomy. So he's, he sells abroad and he takes up residence by Lake Geneva in a villa on the shores of Lake Geneva. And he is joined there by another poet, much less well known than Byron, Percy Bysshe Shelley.
你不能把它们套在货车、马车或其他什么上。因此，有一位男爵，卡尔·德雷斯（Karl Drees），他认为……他是一位发明家。所以他发明了……为了解决这个问题，他发明了一台“Laufmaschine”（跑步机），也就是自行车的原型。哦，这是个好事实。所以这是从中产生的一个积极成果，从无夏之年中产生的一个积极成果，英国文学的一个伟大部门，因为那个夏天，拜伦勋爵在非常黑暗的情况下离开了英格兰。他基本上被充满审判精神的英国媒体和公众取消了，
And Shelley also has a complicated love life. So he's gone with his wife, common law wife, Mary Shelley, daughter of Mary Wollstonecraft, the great feminist, and her half-sister, Claire Claremont, whom Byron promptly gets pregnant. Byron is also there with his physician, Dr. Polidori. So they're all shacked up in this house. They can't go outside because it's miserable weather um the most famous product of this is frankenstein which is a novel that um in which the weather gets progressively worse and worse and worse so to begin with um frankenstein who
呃，因为一起涉及乱伦的婚姻丑闻，以及鸡奸的传言。所以他出海了，并在日内瓦湖畔日内瓦湖岸边的一栋别墅里居住了下来。另一位诗人生存加入了他，他比拜伦知名度低得多，珀西·比希·雪莱（Percy Bysshe Shelley）。
creates this monster is uh living in good weather of course it's a storm lightning that brings the creature to life and by the end of the book he's being chased by uh by by the monster across the arctic wastes so you get some yeah getting colder and colder they've gone back to the ice age um byron tells a story about a vampire uh which then gets written up by dr polidori and basically establishes the prototype of the aristocratic vampire that will feed into Dracula. And so you've got Frankenstein and Dracula basically kind of being born here. You also have a completely terrifying poem that Byron writes about the experience of the darkness that when the Soviet and British scientists presented their joint paper on the way in
而且雪莱的感情生活也很复杂。所以他和他的妻子，事实上的妻子玛丽·雪莱——伟大的女权主义者玛丽·沃斯通克拉夫特的女儿——以及她的异母妹妹克莱尔·克莱尔蒙特一起走了，拜伦很快让克莱尔怀孕了。拜伦的私人医生波利多里博士也在那里。所以他们都挤在这个房子里。他们不能外出，因为天气糟透了，呃，这产生的最著名的产物就是《弗兰肯斯坦》，这是一部小说，呃，其中的天气变得越来越糟，越来越糟，越来越糟。一开始，呃，创造这个怪物的弗兰肯斯坦，呃，生活在好天气里，当然是一场闪电风暴让这个生物苏醒，到书的结尾，他一直在被怪物在北极荒原上追赶，所以你得到了一些，是的，变得越来越冷，他们回到了冰河时代，
which nuclear winters would be one of the results of a nuclear exchange. They put this poem by Byron and a reworking of it by Pushkin in Russian at the head of the paper. Oh, very good. Yeah, it's really good. So I'll just, it's a really, really chilling poem. I mean, I'd urge anyone who hasn't read it to read it because it's fantastic. But I'll just read the opening. I had a dream which was not all a dream. The bright sun was extinguished and the stars did wander darkling in the eternal space, rayless and pathless, and the icy earth swung blind and blackening in the moonless air. Morn came and went and came and brought no day, and men forgot their
拜伦讲述了一个关于吸血鬼的故事，后来被波利多里博士写了下来，并基本确立了后来喂养了《德古拉》的贵族吸血鬼的原型。所以你基本上有了《弗兰肯斯坦》和《德古拉》在这里诞生。你还有一首非常可怕的诗，是拜伦写的，关于黑暗的经历，当苏联和英国的科学家提交关于核战争带来的结果之一将是核冬天的联合论文时，他们在论文的开头引用了拜伦的这首诗以及普希金对其的俄语改写。哦，非常棒。是的，真的很好。所以我只读，这是一首非常非常令人不寒而栗的诗。我的意思是，我敦促任何没有读过它的人去读一读，因为它棒极了。但我只读开头。我做了一个梦，并非全然是梦。灿烂的太阳熄灭了，群星在永恒的空间里黑暗地游荡，没有光芒，没有道路，冰冷的地球在无月的空气中盲目而变黑地摇曳着。清晨来了又去，来了又去，却没有带来白昼，人们在对这种荒凉的恐惧中忘记了他们的
passions in the dread of this, their desolation. And all hearts were chilled into a selfish prayer for light. And so it goes on. That is chilling. And it ends up with the last humans killing each other. Wow. That's very good. I like that.
激情。所有的心都冻结成对光明的自私祈求。事情就是这样发展的。这太让人毛骨悚然了。它以最后的人类互相残杀而告终。哇。这太棒了。我喜欢这个。
So on that cheery note, that's my five. Frankenstein, vampires, nuclear winters. And bicycles. And bicycles. So there's an upside. All right. Well, talking of horror stories, I've got a great... I mean, I've shown immense self-restraint in not doing this first, or indeed every time. It's the winter of discontent.
带着这种欢快的心情，这就是我的五个。弗兰肯斯坦、吸血鬼、核冬天。还有自行车。还有自行车。所以有一个好的一面。好吧，说到恐怖故事，我有一个极好的……我的意思是，我在没有把这个放在第一位，或者事实上没有每次都讲这个方面表现出了极大的自我克制。这就是不满的冬天。
James Callaghan, I knew you'd go for this. It's the winter. Of course. People who are overseas listeners will be bewildered by this um in richard iii shakespeare's play richard says you know now is the winter of our discontent and that the the phrase sort of has stuck in the in the english imagination and um at the end of the 1970s uh the there had been a Labour government since 1974, and they were battling inflation, and they had managed to keep inflation down
詹姆斯·卡拉汉，我就知道你会选这个。这就是冬天。当然。海外听众会对这个感到迷惑，在莎士比亚的戏剧《理查三世》中，理查说，“现在是我们不满的冬天，”这句话深深印在了英国人的想象中，呃，在20世纪70年代末，呃，自1974年以来一直有一个工党政府，他们在与通货膨胀作斗争，他们设法将通货膨胀保持在较低水平
or attempted to reduce inflation by a series of deals with Britain's trade unions. It was a slight myth that Britain's trade unions were more powerful than other people's trade unions. I think part of the problem was there were just more of them, so they were very competitive, always trying to outdo each other in deals for their members. And at the end of 1978, the relationship between the governments and the unions kind of breaks down because James Callaghan,
或者试图通过与英国工会的系列协议来降低通货膨胀。这有点像个神话，即英国工会的权力比其他人的工会更大。我想部分问题在于工会数量更多，因此他们非常有竞争力，总是试图在为会员争取协议时互相攀比。而在1978年底，政府与工会之间的关系破裂了，因为詹姆斯·卡拉汉，
he's postponed, he could have called a general election, but he doesn't want to. He wants to wait till 1979 because he wants to show the public, the voters, that he can work with the unions and basically force them to accept a 5% limit on pay increases, which will help him fight inflation. So he can then say to the public, well, you don't need this awful woman, Margaret Thatcher, who's very extreme because I can do the job much more consensually, and I can get it done, and you don't need her. But first of all, the union members refuse to accept it. But secondly, that coincides with this period of awful weather. So the worst winter in Britain since 1962, you get massive snow drifts across the country, you get roads closed, you get people
他推迟了，他本可以宣布举行大选，但他不想这么做。他想等到1979年，因为他想向公众、选民表明，他可以与工会合作，并基本上迫使他们接受对加薪5%的限制，这将有助于他打击通货膨胀。这样他就可以对公众说，嗯，你们不需要这个极其极端的玛格丽特·撒切尔夫人，因为我可以以更具共识的方式完成工作，我能搞定，你们不需要她。但首先，工会成员拒绝接受这一点。但其次，这与一段恶劣的天气时期不期而遇。所以这是自1962年以来英国最糟糕的冬天，全国各地出现了大量厚厚的积雪，道路封闭，人们
freezing to death in their cars, and so on. that and this coincides with as some of our older listeners will remember a series of crippling strikes it starts with a lorry driver's strike kind of over christmas and then you have the roads are obviously blocked by snow but you have rail strike you know the railways shut down you have shops running out of groceries and sort of you know images that we are perhaps now a tiny bit more familiar with because of the kind of panic buying during the pandemic but at the time are very shocking to people the fact that um your local corner shop has run out of bread because of a strike or something now you know the weather plays a huge part in this but what compounds this is that precisely this point callahan who's been
在汽车里冻死，等等。而这恰逢——正如我们的一些老听众会记得的那样——一连串瘫痪性的罢工。它始于圣诞节前夕的卡车司机罢工，然后道路显然被雪封锁了，但你还有铁路罢工，你知道铁路关闭了，商店的杂货卖光了，你知道——这些画面我们现在可能因为大流行期间的抢购而稍微熟悉了一点，但在当时对人们来说非常震撼，因为罢工或其他原因，你当地的街角杂货店面包卖光了——现在，你知道，天气在其中起了很大的作用，但雪上加霜的是，正是在这个时候，卡拉汉——到目前为止他一直是一位相当受欢迎的首相——去了一个，偏偏是在瓜德罗普岛的峰会。所以他飞去了瓜德罗普岛，他带着——所有这些照片传回英国，照片上他在海滩上用椰子喝着东西。夏威夷衫。他穿着一件夏威夷衫。是吗？他们都穿着这些，嗯，他们穿着某种类似萨利征服者套装的衣服，因为那是70年代。所以是他。
quite a popular prime minister till now goes off to a um a summit in of all places guadalupe so he flies off to guadalupe and he had and there are all these pictures coming back to um to britain of him on the beach kind of drinking out of coconuts. Hawaiian shirt. He wears a Hawaiian shirt. Does he? They're all in these, well, they're sort of in safari suit type arrangements because it's the 70s. So it's him.
我想还有赫尔穆特·施密特。他是一个相当喜欢玩乐的人。吉米·卡特当然不喜欢玩乐。所以他可能很不高兴。但我想也许瓦莱里·吉斯卡尔·德斯坦也在那里。
I think there's Helmut Schmidt. He's quite a sort of, he likes a good time. Jimmy Carter, of course, doesn't like a good time. So he's probably quite miserable. But I think maybe Valerius Giscard d'Estaing might be there.
我不记得了。他喜欢钻石，不是吗？他确实喜欢钻石。他喜欢非洲钻石。不管怎样，他们都在那里，他们在瓜德罗普岛玩得很开心。卡拉汉随后要回国，但他说，好吧，我不会马上回家，因为我面临着
I can't remember. He likes a diamond diamond doesn't he? He does like a diamond He likes an African diamond So anyway, they're all there, they're having a whale of a time in Guadeloupe Callaghan then he's going to come home but he says well I won't go home straight away because I'm facing
你知道，国内由于工会之类的事情一切都相当严峻，所以最理想的事情是在回国前在巴巴多斯休息几天，他也确实这么做了。现在他完全可以合情合理地说首相是允许休假的。我工作极其努力。
you know, it's all pretty grim at home with his unions and stuff so the ideal thing would be to have a few days break in Barbados before I come home, which he does. Now he can reasonably say prime ministers are allowed a holiday. I've been working incredibly hard.
我们经历了1976年的国际货币基金组织危机。你知道，我需要几天时间——而且真的只是几天时间——来充电。但当然，舰队街的摄影师们都在那里，他们拍到了非常棒的照片，
We've had the international monetary fund crisis of 1976. You know, I need a couple of days and it really is just a couple of days to recharge. But of course, the Fleet Street photographers are there and they get these fantastic photos
照片里他像一头巨大的猛犸象或其他什么东西一样潜伏在浅水区，在巴巴多斯海滩上打量着穿比基尼的姑娘们。与此同时在家里，没有火车，一切都冻结了。尸体没有被埋葬，对吧？因为掘墓人在现场。好吧，这正要发生。哦，对不起。我为你搞砸了。不，不，不。我的意思是，很多人都会这么想。所以他回到机场，在机场召开了那场灾难性的新闻发布会。
of him kind of lurking like a great mammoth or something in the shallows, inspecting girls in bikinis on the beaches of Barbados. While meanwhile at home, there's no trains, everything is frozen. And the bodies aren't being buried, are they? Because the grave diggers are on site. Well, that's about to come actually. Oh, I'm sorry. I've ruined it for you. No, no, no. I mean, lots of people will have been thinking exactly that. So then he comes home and gives this disastrous press conference at the airport.
他晒得很黑。他穿着一套夏装。他说：“我不知道你们怎么从外面来看待这件事。我觉得国内的事情可能挺好的。我不知道你们在抱怨什么。”这就是《太阳报》著名头条的由来：“危机，什么危机？”轻率的吉姆，我想。而他从未说过这话，对吧？
He's really tanned. He's wearing a sort of summer suit. And he says, I don't know what you're looking at it from outside. I think things in prison are probably fine. I don't know what you're complaining about. And that's what you get the Sun's famous headline, crisis, what crisis? Jaunty Jim, I think. Which he never said, did he?
而他从未说过。是的，轻率的吉姆回家了，并把责任归咎于媒体之类的事情。是的。这相当不合时宜。在此之前，他一直是一位沟通大师。然后天气变得更糟而不是更好。雪更多了。更多的冻雾和所有这些。
Which he never says. Yeah, jaunty Jim comes home and blames the press or something. Yeah. And this is sort of very tone deaf. Somebody was always up to that point, a master of communications. And then the weather gets worse rather than better. There's more snow. There's more freezing fog and all this stuff.
更多的人开始罢工。那时候所有的学校都关门了，利物浦的掘墓人也开始罢工。所以尸体，人们的尸体被放在冷藏仓库里，你会看到所有这些，我想《每日邮报》有一个头条：“我们甚至不能埋葬我们的死者，或者他们不让我们埋葬我们的死者，”诸如此类。
More people go out on strike. That's when you get the, all the schools are shut and you get the gravediggers in Liverpool going on strike. So the bodies, people's bodies are put in refrigerated warehouses and you get all these, I think the Daily Mail has a headline, we can't even bury our dead or they won't let us bury our dead or something.
所以，人们的垃圾桶没有被清空。是的，莱斯特广场有大量堆积的垃圾，是的，我的意思是这些是不满的冬天的最著名的照片，而且有一种，总是有这样一种政治学派，基本上认为这一切都与垃圾桶和垃圾清运有关，是的，而且大多数人对任何政治事情都不感兴趣，我认为这有一定道理，但如果他们的垃圾桶没有被清空，他们绝对会大发雷霆。不帮你清垃圾的政府将会为此付出代价。当然，卡拉汉的政府确实为此付出了代价。在大选中，他们本可以做得好得多，我想。
So, and people's bins don't get collected. yes the key huge piles in leicester square yeah that's i mean these are the most famous photos of the winter discontent and there's this sort of um there's always there's this whole school of thought with politics that basically it's all about bins and bin collections yeah and that most people don't care about anything political i think there's a degree of truth in this but if their bins aren't collected, they're absolutely outraged. And the government that doesn't collect your bins will suffer for it. And of course, Callaghan's government does suffer for it. They would have done far better, I think, in the general election.
他们可能不会赢得大选，但如果没有垃圾桶、坟墓、大雪、“危机，什么危机”以及所有这些乱七八糟的事情，他们本来会表现得好得多。当然，保守党随后基本上靠着“不满的冬天”这一事件大快朵颐，为了什么，他们的下一个……我的意思是，他们在1997年还在使用它。难以置信的是，他们在针对托尼·布莱尔的广告中仍然在使用它。如果托尼·布莱尔上台，你当然是个托尼·布莱尔的大粉丝。
They might not have won it, but they'd have done far better had it not been for the bins, the graves, the snow, the crisis, what crisis, and all that sort of stuff. And of course, the Conservatives then basically dine out on the winter of discontent for what, their next... I mean, they were still using it in 1997. Unbelievably, they were still using it in their ads against Tony Blair. If Tony Blair gets in, you're of course a big Tony Blair man.
我想大概直到黑色星期三。是的。在那之后，我的意思是，因为“不满的冬天”是笼罩工党的灾难。然后黑色星期三是笼罩工党的灾难。然后黑色星期三是笼罩托利党的灾难。完全如此。绝对如此。所以即使在1997年，托利党仍然在说，如果工党重新上台，他们不会埋葬你们的死者。
I suppose really until Black Wednesday. Yeah. Which then, I mean, because the winter of discontent is the disaster that shadows Labour. And then Black Wednesday is the disaster that shadows Labour. And then Black Wednesday is the disaster that shadows the Tories. Exactly. Exactly so. So even in 1997, the Tories are still saying, if Labour get back in, they won't bury your dead.
他们不会清理你们的垃圾桶，而且会一直下雪。但我想到了那个时候，正如你所说，黑色星期三已经介入。所以这种叙事已经失去了它的效力。是的。好吧，这是一个很好的结束语。非常不错。我们应该请你谈谈快乐的吉姆。
They won't empty your bins and it'll snow all the time. But I think by that point, as you say, Black Wednesday has intervened. And so that narrative has lost its force. Yeah. Okay. Well, that's a great note on which to end. Very good. We should have you talking about Sonny Jim.
那么你有什么？在播客结束时谈论吉姆·卡拉汉总是很好的。那么，汤姆，在你自己选择的天气选项中，你最喜欢哪一个？你可以选择一个。好吧，刚从克雷斯韦尔峭壁（Creswell Crags）回来，他们在游客中心有一个非常棒的视频。我知道“游客中心”这个词会让任何人感到一丝寒意
So what do you have? It's always good to talk about Jim Callahan at the end of a podcast. So which is your favourite of these, of your own weather choices, Tom? You could choose one. Well, having just come back from Creswell Crags, they have this amazing video in the Visitor Centre. I know that the phrase Visitor Centre strikes a chill
但在任何……但这是一个很棒的游客中心。他们使用的雪兔毛的小碎片。他们用雪兔的内脏来缝制皮草和其他东西。等一下，雪兔？
in any... But this is a great Visitor Centre. Little fragments of snow hair that they used. They used the guts of the snow hair to sew their furs and things. Hold on, snow hare?
什么是雪兔？北极兔，你知道的。白色的毛皮。你抓住它们，用它们做针、线之类的东西。是的。但他们有一个非常棒的视频，向你展示了12万年前诺丁汉郡和德比郡的荒地。
What's snow hare? Arctic hare, you know. White fur. And you kind of capture them and you make needles out of them and thread and stuff. Yeah. But they have a kind of wonderful video where they show you the Nottinghamshire Derbyshire Badlands in 120,000 years ago.
德比郡的荒地。有河马在四处漫步。所以他们有河马。然后他们有，我展示了大约6万年前尼安德特人存在并且有土拨鼠（应为鬣狗）的时候。然后他们有那种《权力的游戏》式的视频，
Badlands of Derbyshire. And there are hippos wandering around. So they had hippos. Then they have, I showed about 60,000 years ago when there are Neanderthals there and there are hyenas. Then they've got the kind of Game of Thrones one
我刚才说的，在那里你有，你有托马斯·阿皮安斯出现并做这些洞穴艺术。然后你有维多利亚时代的人四处游荡，进行探矿。看起来非常华丽和美丽。听起来不错。作为游客中心来说？
that I was talking about, where you've got, you've got Thomas Appians turning up and doing this cave art. And then you've got Victorians wandering around, prospecting. And it's looking all kind of gorgeous and beautiful. That sounds good. As visitor centres go?
这是一个美妙的地方。它非常有氛围，真的非常有趣。基本上，这就是英国艺术开始的地方。好吧。你游说成功了。是的。我想你的选择是“不满的冬天”。你知道吗？
It's a wonderful place. It's very atmospheric, really, really interesting. And basically, it's where British art begins. Okay. You've persuaded me. Yeah. And yours, I guess, is Winter of Discontent. You know what?
我实际上要选择“大北方战争”。这听起来最浪漫。我喜欢东欧的故事。我喜欢我不太了解的东西，这就是为什么我在播客中选择它的原因。而且，我也只是认为他五年没有回家这一事实。是的，这是一个很棒的细节。但“大北方战争”。
I'm actually going to pick The Great Northern War. It's the most romantic sounding. I like an Eastern European story. I like stuff I don't really know about, which is why I pick it in podcasts. And also, I just think the fact that he didn't go home for five years. Yeah, that's a great detail. But The Great Northern War.
这要宏大得多。北方战争基本上就像一个电子游戏，不是吗？伪装成历史或其他什么。或者像一部奇幻小说。好吧，其实我们俩都是，因为我有一道伟大的冰墙，而你拥有大北方战争。我的意思是，这其中有一定的协同作用。是的，历史上的所有东西最后都回到了《权力的游戏》或托尔金，
It's so much more. It's basically a video game, isn't it Northern War, it's so much more. It's a video game, isn't it? Masquerading as history or something. Or like a fantasy novel. Well, actually, both of us, because I've got a Great Wall of Ice and you've got the Great Northern War. I mean, there's a certain synergy there. Yeah, everything comes back to Game of Thrones or Tolkien,
不是吗，基本上。带着这个音符。是的。所以我们要离开你们了。感谢我的老伙计约翰·廷克（John Tinker）的建议，呃，你采纳那个建议了吗，因为他很有钱，而你想吃一顿丰盛的大餐？算是吧，为了让其他听众绝对清楚，我认为这是一个非常好的机会，我非常乐意接受贿赂来推荐话题。你可以通过推特联系我。
doesn't it, basically, in history. On that note. Yes. So we shall leave you. Thanks to my old mucker john tinker for the suggestion um did you did you take that up because he's very rich and you're hoping for a slap up meal some sort of i just to be absolutely clear for other listeners i think this is a very good opportunity i would happily take bribes to suggest for topics. You can contact me on Twitter.
你知道，我们可以搞一次拍卖。你知道吗？我们可以搞一次拍卖，汤姆。我们举办一场慈善拍卖。慈善拍卖？不，实际上，我们直接办一场拍卖吧。是的，我们直接办一场拍卖吧。
You know, we could have an auction. Do you know what? We could have an auction, Tom. We have a charity auction. Charity auction? No, actually, let's just have an auction. Yeah, let's just have an auction.
让我们彻底把自己卖了吧。我很想办慈善拍卖。因为你有你的募捐诉求。是的，我有我的义演。所以我很想这么做。但我唯一的焦虑是，如果我们得到类似的东西，我不知道，1830年加泰罗尼亚的政治之类的。我认为我们应该去做。
Let's just sell ourselves completely. I'm very tempted to do the charity auction. Because you've got your appeal. Yes, I've got my benefit. So I'm very tempted to do that. But my only anxiety is if we get something like, I don't know, the politics of Catalonia in 1830 or something. I think we should do it.
我认为我们应该向听众全面开放。如果是1830年加泰罗尼亚的政治，你知道，我认为我们应该——好吧，那绝对可以成为话题，那绝对可以成为播客的标题，至于我们是否坚持这个主题——是的，是的，好吧，那我们该这么做吗？那就这么做吧，为什么不呢？为了慈善，我们把它拿来拍卖。好吧，如果你想让我们做一个特定的主题，并且你准备为我们的慈善募捐活动支付一大笔钱，这项活动旨在帮助无家可归者和雅兹迪难民
I think we should throw this open to the listeners. And if it is the politics of catalonia in 1830 you know i think we should okay so that can certainly be the topic that can certainly be the title of the podcast whether we stick to the subject yes yes okay so should we do that then let's do that yeah why not okay for the benefit'll auction it. Okay, so if you want us to do a particular topic and you're prepared to pay a fat sum of money towards our benefit appeal, which is going towards the homeless and to Yazidi refugees,
我觉得我们应该向听众开放这个。如果那是1830年加泰罗尼亚的政治，你知道的，我想我们应该——好的，那当然可以成为这个话题，那当然可以成为播客的标题，不管我们是否坚持这个主题——是的，是的，好的，那我们该那样做吗？我们就这么办吧，对，为什么不呢？好的，为了筹款，我们要把它拿出来拍卖。好的，所以如果你想让我们做一个特定的主题，并且你愿意为我们的慈善募捐支付一大笔钱，这笔钱将用于无家可归者和雅兹迪难民，
so sensational cause, let us know. And we should probably try and put this on some kind of official footnote. This is probably not a charity commission basis. And I'm afraid that the evidence is now there, isn't it? Yeah, it is. So you heard it here first. This is the first step in the road that will take Tom Holland to prison
如此耸人听闻的案件，请让我们知道。我们或许应该试着把它列入某种官方脚注。这大概不属于慈善委员会的管辖范围。恐怕证据现在已经确凿了，对吧？是的，确实如此。所以你们是第一批听说的。这是通往将汤姆·霍兰德送进监狱之路的第一步
for embezzling listeners' money. And on that note, we shall see you next time. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community,
罪名是挪用听众的资金。就此而言，我们下次再见。再见。拜拜。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的剩余》。想要获取独家单集、抢先收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。